josée Aldo backed out who's gonna fight
you backed out and said it was due to a
rib injury but he's been cleared to
fight by a doctor what do you think
happened I mean the man is running
scared I can I cannot force a man who is
not willing to step in a fight I kind of
forced him into the octagon to face me
but really I cannot hold any grudge
towards him because I would not want to
face me either you were going to destroy
him you and that was you think it was
pure fear he's the reason he backed out
it it he has been medically cleared to
fight doctors have looked at him
examined him he went and saw a
gynecologist on the
[Applause]
alright that brings us to Chad Mendes
Chad Mendes is now who you're going to
fight Chad Mendes is out there saying
talking trash about you if you haven't
heard me saying let's take a look now
god it's gonna feel so good to get in
there and punch a hole through Conor
McGregor space and just dismantle this
dude and take his head off and if I
don't do that I'm gonna put him on his
back and make it one hell of a night for
him I'm gonna put Conor McGregor in my
back pocket for now and keep him there
until it's time to whoop his ass can I
just say when a man says to me I'm gonna
put you on your back and give you the
night of your life after he said that I
said sounds romantic
he can talk all he wants but you know
face to face man to man they crumble and
every every time every time I face
against one of these individuals they
break so he will be no different
[Applause]
obviously your your your sport is
different than than than boxing than
just pure boxing you are the same weight
as Mayweather you are that you guys are
the same about the same weight ya 145
pounds was to fight against Pacquiao and
my fight is 145 pounds okay so you're
the saint you're in the same weight
class what if you were in the ring with
Floyd Mayweather what do you think would
happen he's obviously an incredibly one
of the greatest boxers anyone's ever
seen if you're asking what I like to
fight Floyd I mean who would not like to
dance around the ring for 100 million
[Applause]
yeah but if if we were to fight in I
know I certainly know he would not want
to step into my world the world of pure
unarmed combat whether I'm combat where
there is no limitations but I most
certainly would step into his world and
I would certainly box him if the
opportunity arose most most sadly
talking about there's no real fight in
boxing left for Floyd anyway them after
the money fight happened that's it
there's nothing no more real boys if
you're looking to a fight that could
generate interest it must be across as a
match of different styles that's meaning
I've said it before I don't feel boxing
is the style of fighting that can be
Floyd but saying that there are many
many forms of fighting that can't beat
him so if we were to get it on I would
most gently dismantle him also hey
thanks for watching be sure to click
subscribe to see even more great Conan
clips you may now return to your pirated
movies and creepy Japanese pornography